donald glover caps off his amazing week
at the solo premiere while selena
gomez's back but is her new song about
bieber plus more new music friday pics
happy friday friends last night was the
world premiere of solo a Star Wars story
and they literally shut down Hollywood
Boulevard probably because they needed
to park this guy yep that's the
Millennium Falcon right in the middle of
the red carpet and it was a solo mission
that put Hollywood at a standstill I
gotta say all eyes are on Donald Glover
who posed on the red carpet alongside
Billy Dee Williams aka the original
Lando not sure if they coordinated their
red outfits there but it's clear that
for Donald playing young Lando and being
part of the Star Wars family is a trick
it's it's a dream it really is a dream I
never thought I'd be able to be a part
of it like I've went as a child I used
to play with the toys I used to I used
to watch the movie like my I had like a
VHS of it then my dad ripped from a
laserdisc I'm speaking gibberish to
anybody born after 1987 but but it was
it was pivotal for me and like to be
part of his family and to be able to
play young Lando was like a hero of mine
it's like truly it's just stuff that
dreams are made of so I feel really
blessed what's the reaction been about
you landing Lando Calrissian and being
part of this like what kind of feedback
we get I was told by my mom not to mess
it up okay
which you know is I'm saying we'll find
out you know in a couple of minutes
that's why she's not invited the massive
premiere caps off an equally epic week
for Donald is started with hosting SNL
and of course the release of his
politically charged music video this is
America it has been nearly 80 million
YouTube views in less than a week and
that number is still climbing because we
can't stop watching it I gotta say is
well it is stunning and I was saying
that it's almost too hard to watching it
you can't look away
and then you got to watch it again one
because there's so much going on in the
video but it's mainly because childish
gambino made a high quality piece of art
with powerful and unapologetic social
commentary this word gets overused
especially by me but I am shook by it
all and so is the cast of Netflix's dear
white people who praise Gambino for
getting folks talking about gun violence
and race relations in America we need to
be talking about gun violence and in the
United States like we just it needs to
be a conversation that we need to have
and and because children are dying
period point-blank but like to have to
speak of that and then like have the
racial undertones and like even him
being like runt like people running
after him at the end like like like a
slave running off of a plantation laters
the visuals of it I just thought it was
you have to watch back and keep running
and things get better going on behind
him you can get caught up in him like
doing this thing be like you get Donald
getting it oh yeah it kind of like it's
a macho kind of just show you like are
we tap dance at like I mean I feel like
so many people have their time too heavy
though heavy and deep but I gotta say
this is America is just one of the songs
we got to talk about this week so let's
get into our new music Friday picks
starting with a big one that has been
trending today Rita Ora and her
star-studded girl squad of cardi B bebe
Rexha and Charli XCX their song is being
touted as a bisexual anthem but I say
it's just an anthem about living your
truth
here's girls
[Music]
Rita told billboard she was a huge fan
of the Spice Girls and just loved the
idea of bringing some girls together to
do something extra powerful girl power
speaking of Selena Gomez dropped a new
track called back to you off the 13
reasons why season 2 soundtrack Selena
co-wrote it and we're definitely picking
up some potential Justin Bieber
references
[Music]
[Music]
giggles you
I know I go back to you
[Music]
it has been a roller coaster of a year
for Celine's she and Biebs have been off
and on and after taking a break from the
spotlight she also underwent a kidney
transplant last year and today Selena's
other ex the weekend was spotted kissing
his ex Bella Hadid at a party at the can
Film Festival they called it quits just
before the weekend started dating Selena
and they say a picture tells a thousand
words and I'd say these two are still
quite close meanwhile one of my favorite
bands years and years are not interested
in staying friends on their new bubbly
pop if you're over me
[Music]
me
[Music]
I'll turn my but I need baby is over me
if
[Music]
yep my new jam for the weekend I hope
you guys enjoyed these pics let me know
in the comments what you guys are
listening to but also a quick massive
thank you to everybody who watched the
daily Denny this week following the Met
Gala all next week we've got a special
surprise for you we are going live every
day at 12 p.m. Pacific as we countdown
to the Royal Wedding so make sure you
guys tune in right here and I'll see you
on Monday have a good weekend everybody
[Music]